EPAIRING THE PANDEMI
D REPORTING
ISOUCOMPANY SONS
S CAPTURE 6TH CAPITAL RIOTEREPWW
FROMUSEAKSMES ABOUT THE RE
PARTY YOUTUBEALITY
RIOT AT THE CAPITOL TRAVELED
WITH A GROUP OF HOUSS TO THE
IF THAT ISN'T SHOCKINGUGTH
TOORDER WEREA  ION THAT  OEATIN
NGE JANUARY 6T
ECTIONFI
OS THIS CRITICAREPO
ANDREW, WALK US THUGYOU'VE LEARW
BASICALLY AS YOU
YOUTUBHO A PREVIOUSLRTED IS E F
ED, TOAR
CAPITOL RIOT, WEE
JUSTIFIEY CRITICIZED
BREAKING IN.ER
HEOM MEMBERS
THE FROM THE REPUBLICASTY
COMMITTEE, AND THEY TRAVELE BORD
TRUMP'S VISIT.
EXY HEOINED THE P T THE SETY- I
SEE IN THE PHOTOS AND VIDEOS ST
SURE HOW HE THERE.QUITE
THIS?EMBERS AB
>>E OFFICE OF
REPUBLICAN J BE CHAIR
T WHO
ORGANIZED THE TRIPHE SAID THEY N
THL RIOTR O  W
AND TH
WITHM O BORDER, SO HE WA'T PARO
SO THEY SAID THE KNOW
BUT AS CY
INTIMATELY INVOLVED INS
D YO, JUST --
WH. GROUP OF AALF
RENAWARE
WHO AS H